welcome so let's see if we can figure
out what 8 divided by 0.4
is pause this video and see if you can
work through that
all right so we're trying to figure out
what eight ones divided by four tenths
is
and so one way to think about it that is
to think about everything in terms of
tenths
so eight ones one one is equal to ten
tenths so eight ones is equal to eighty
tenths so this is equal to 80 tenths
and i'm dividing it by four tenths
so divided by four tenths
so if i have 80 tenths and if i want to
divide it into equal groups of four
tenths how many equal groups am i going
to have
well i am going to have 20 equal groups
of four-tenths that would make up
eighty-tenths eighty divided by four is
twenty so eight divided by 4 10 is equal
to 20. another way that we could have
approached that is we could have thought
about it in terms of fractions we could
have said hey 8 divided by 4 tenths
that's the same thing as 8
divided by
4
10
which is the same thing when you divide
by a fraction it's the same thing as
multiplying by the reciprocal so this is
the same thing as
8
times
10
over 4 or you could view it as the same
thing as 8 over 1
8
ones times 10 over 4
times 10 over 4. in your numerator you
get 8 times 10 so that is going to be
equal to i'll do it in this orange color
8 times 10 is equal to 80 and then in
our denominator we're going to have 1
times 4.
i didn't circle the one yeah you're
going to have the 1 times the 4 so
that's just going to be equal to 4. so
80 fourths or 80 divided by 4 once again
that is going to be equal to 20.
let's do another example but in this
case let's let's deal with things let's
deal with hundredths let's draw a line
here
and so let's say that someone walks up
to you on the street and says quick
what is 48
divided by
0.24 pause this video and see if you can
figure that out and i'll give you a
little bit of a hint the techniques we
just did might apply although now we're
dealing with hundredths
all right now let's work on this
together
well one way to work on it is you could
view this as 48 you could just convert
everything to fractions as 48 and
actually i can just write it as 48 over
1
divided by
divided by
24 hundredths
24
hundredths this division sign looks a
little bit weird let me make it look a
little bit more normal there you go and
so when you divide by a fraction that's
the same thing as multiplying by the
reciprocal we've seen that before so
this is equal to
48 over 1
times 100 twenty-fourths
and so our numerator here is going to be
equal to 48 times 100 actually i'm just
going to write that out as 48 times 100
in the numerator and then our
denominator is going to be 24 times 1
well that's just equal to 24. and so
what is this going to be equal to
48 times 100 divided by 24
well we could divide the numerator and
the denominator by 24. if we did that 48
divided by 24 is 2 and 24 divided by 24
is 1 so we're left with 2 times 100
divided by 1 well 2 times 100 is equal
to 200 and then you divide that by 1 you
still get 200.
so there you have it this is equal to
200. now another way that you could have
approached this
is you could have thought about
everything again in terms of hundredths
and so 48 ones is the same thing as 4
800 hundredths
so it's equal to
48
48 hundred
hundredths
so let me write that down hundredths
divided by 24 hundredths
divided by 24
hundredths
so if i have 4 800 or 4 800 hundredths
and if i want to divide into equal
groups of 24 hundredths how many of
those equal groups would i have
well you would have 4 800 divided by 24
equal groups so this is going to be
equal to
4800
4800 divided by 24.
now 4800 is exactly what we had up here
and so we already saw that 4800 divided
by 24 is equal to 200
and if you just got to this point and if
you said hey how could i work on this
you could just say hey let me divide the
numerator and denominator by 24 you
could try to re-express 4 800 as 48
times 100 or you could even say that 48
is 24 times 2 and then you're going to
multiply that times 100 to get to 4 800
and then the division is a little bit
more straightforward but the big picture
here is to realize that dividing by
decimals is not some mysterious thing
when you think about it in terms of
place value or when you think about it
in terms of fractions